somebody says to you you know what is a
woman and you don't know you don't think
Hano itself it's like a bit anti-women
because panel uh like mine like the the
show panels we don't really have like
you know you don't have a there's only
panels of gas yeah yeah but I think
she's I think she's just saying the
podcast is anti-women you know it's like
why would she come on then if it's
anti-women oh she did I didn't know it
was only women until I got there when
you say something she she brings all
these stats yeah to basically hahaha
you confused her with the stats why
don't you go with your feelings why
didn't you go with yourself it's gonna
be something she's lacking in her
argument yeah she has zero facts to
support and the thing is is that when I
go to church and it would if the if the
pastor says something I will write it
down and I will go but I won't say yeah
yeah I believe him I will write it down
in a book and I can I've got years of
them every time I go to a church I write
down what they say and I want to go and
look for it for myself and I mean
everybody keeps announce good where'd
you get these stats from why don't you
say the stats I know I always say Google
it Google it you want to find out Google
they're never happy even if I give it to
them like I was on this podcast and
they're if you're talking about body
count I was talking about the data on
body count they said where I said the
CDC
for Disease Control and and they're
still not happy they're never happy now
you make up statistics how many times
have you given a fact and a guest
changed their opinion because the fact
they're like you know what I was wrong
the point I just made actually more than
you'd think okay yeah like I had a
couple girls say they don't believe
they're feminists anymore I had a couple
um I have it in a while because
uh the shows we've been doing are more
like they just haven't been geared this
way but like I didn't show and there was
a couple people that said they were
going to be pro-life after the show and
the thing is that not the majority I
would say it would be like 10 20 but
even pills none of us to you know be an
influence and changing them on and she's
wrong you've done that with zooby you
know like I remember you had a
percentage and when he explained himself
you were like you know what I'll give
you an extra 10 I think you said or
something like that so even pearls I
mean my view is like if you if you think
I'm saying something wrong prove me
wrong change my mind and prove me wrong
but don't say that I'm wrong but you
can't tell me where I'm going wrong you
know it's it's stupid and then stats you
prove like my conversation she was
saying that women are bad with money
yeah
the guy just said which they are she's
still cutting across still cutting
across him and he said women are bad
with money background like African women
are the best with money is that how you
feel yeah
listen to my words I'm saying do you do
your steps according to African women
Caribbean women white women American
women aren't the statues women in
general it's the women owned two-thirds
thirds of Consumer Debt worldwide
actually was looking into Nigerian women
um their credit card debt
um if it's gonna say credit card fraud
no no no no no no no no no no I couldn't
find it find much data on like
specifically Nigerian women because it
was those you know um I think that was
one of the ones she said
um what I found was like I think women
are locked out of credit card markets
there and I'm like maybe there's a
reason for it there's a lot of fraud
going on that's why so that's why they
have to be good with cash okay is how
you feel though no it's not about how I
feel my reality women are very good what
do the stats say I don't feel but my
reality your reality is still your
feelings because not stats what are you
gonna back it up with my reality she
doesn't live in the reality because she
doesn't know what a woman is talking
about discussion women to yours okay
now there's shouting all over the host
it's his show shut up yeah that's the
how many y'all you know what I know
they're gonna watch this and I just want
you both to know how many times have we
counted I can't even count how many
times you've interrupted hosts that's
right and then when I'm talking about my
point of view you and then what I was
getting was in so in comments so
um as Auntie Jenny that's me you've rude
woman I can be rude
thank you Eddie I love you Eddie
People You can disagree with someone's
opinion without like saying oh you're
just confused now if I'm asking you as a
woman what a woman is
and you're telling me that you bleed
three times a month
and then you created yourself and said
oh no I only bleed once come on you
don't know how many how much you believe
and then we're explaining to you about
biology and you are saying that being a
woman surely can't be about biology
being a woman is about feeling like a
woman so anyone that feels like a woman
can be a woman of course I'm gonna say
you're confused I still stick with that
you are confused you're upset with me
that you're confused because you are a
woman and you don't know what a woman is
now you're upset because I called you
confused look at the podcast you are
confused so this is this is social media
you know but even coming
no I feel like you can just be like oh I
hear what you're saying I just don't
agree because my reaction
and people want to watch this all the
chat we don't want that's what
people want to see but even coming he's
right she did chat
they want to see the questions to your
podcast did you bring her Eddie's the
one that said that you recruited him and
they said that they yeah I think Eddie
recruited her right because know she was
going to be there Attica to make sure
that people are not being insulted it's
etiquette not to interrupt people when
you're on a podcast you know in the
comments right her followers
comments have nothing to do with pearl
you are warned about the super chess
before you start the show and if you
make you and Paul always warns you if
you make yourself look like an idiot
they will come for you yeah I tell them
before I always say that super chats are
mean if you don't want somebody to know
something pulses don't say it don't say
it because if they come at you pulses
it's not my fault so she can't accuse
Pearl because you know that Pearl's
gonna read out the super chats everybody
knows that Pearl's gonna read out the
super chats so how can you blame Pearl
for the super chats you were acting
stupid you acting confused so of course
she's gonna have to say something I
gotta say that because she didn't know
what a woman was she did not know what a
woman was so of course I'm gonna say
that she's
racist they were racist they are they
said things like white where did you
bring this to generate Nigerian women
okay hang on wait till after that he
says something I remember he says
they said you are degenerate and
Nigerian which is what the person said
but now because she's realized that
she's up there saying oh I'm Nigerian
now they realize she's a degenerate
Nigerian she's trying to make it sound
as if all we're saying all Nigerian
women no love I know some really good
Clipper Nigerian women you're the one
you're the one as the man said they are
talking about you and you know what I
feel like I feel like they they
clarified this because okay I feel like
it's because normally Nigerian women are
not degenerates like I think that's why
they said it was because like it's
abnormal they couldn't say like I like
I've had so many Nigerian women on their
show on the show and they're usually
like more submissive they're usually
very much believe in like respect to
their husbands and that sort of thing
but the thing is they couldn't say
degenerate woman otherwise that would be
bad for all women they couldn't say
degenerate black woman because otherwise
that would be the jet for all women so
they had to say you are where did you
get this degenerate Nigerian from this
degenerative Nigerian not all of them
she must be the only Nigerian woman in
the whole world that doesn't know what a
woman is of course they're gonna say
that she does not know what a woman is
he's generating Nigerian women that's
suggesting now Nigerian women are they
said woman they didn't say women
generally no it's not but it's also
she's not representing just Nigeria
though you're just talking about she
come up there when all Nigerians are
proud to represent Nigeria everybody
comes on it oh I'm Nigerian I'm from
this this is my tribe they all do it
they all do it no I don't know it's like
the Obi tribe and then there's like two
people I mean you know better
or something yoga or Yoruba or something
and I I mean I Loosely know about it
because like literally there's so many
Nigerian people that have come on the
show and they're all so proud yes
if you just said oh I don't agree with
what this woman is saying fair enough
that's not reality bringing my Nigerian
into it that's basically custom
Nigerians and she's born and bred here
by the way right are you stop are you
starting a podcast she's born and bred
here so what they're trying to say that
they should call the English now if they
call if somebody says to me oh English
woman I always say oh somebody says
where do you come from as a black woman
you don't even know born here you don't
say oh I come from England you always
say oh I'm from Barbados or I'm from
Nigeria Mo I say like 90 of your black
guests that come here are actually born
in the UK but they don't say that well
and I think it's not normal to say that
your your black British unless it's in
the form and I think it's a common like
second maybe third generation thing
because like I'm so far removed like I'm
mostly German Irish like Lithuanian well
yeah like those but further up but
further back they would have said oh I'm
from Germany just say American yeah but
I put myself in her shoes I'm like okay
if I was if I was from like so I would
say I don't I I don't even like this
word identify the most with I grew up
with German nannies yeah so I kind of
know about them yeah true the most and
if they said like this degenerate German
woman I wouldn't say that's racist yeah
you just say that's a new one
if he was
and that's why
and she understood podcast etiquette she
shut her mouth and try listening and let
other people speak she obviously don't
understand it I want to bring my guest
on and I see I didn't bring her on she
came on like derogatory comments and
actually read it out to my guests but
you know she's gonna read it out it's
printed up that the super chats are
going to be read out before the show
starts it's all there don't chew gum go
to the toilet now switch off your phones
don't move down the mic and then Pearl
stands up and she always tells you about
the super chats you know they're going
to be read out but because she wasn't
shown in a good light that's why she's
upset and she was shown in a good light
she wouldn't be upset and some of them
are really nice yeah and the thing is
like oh there's some nasty ones have you
yeah when I when I would go off on one
on the rear occasion and you know I
stood by I think I apologize once
because I realized like I did go over
the top but yeah but um overall like
they can be really nice too and
sometimes they're informative and the
thing is like there's just so many super
chats that a lot of times I don't even
that's why I'm so bad at reading them
there's so many and I don't even know
what I'm reading half the time sometimes
I don't even clock it until after I read
and occasionally if they're really bad I
might I might skip one if they're really
really bad but that's like oh you will
wound them I've had to warn people like
you know I'm sorry like I've seen the
super chats I'm gonna read them but you
know especially the young ones you
normally like say like don't it affect
you and I'm really sorry but you know
this is what you're saying but it's not
me you always say it's not me and and
the other thing is like to me I just
feel like if people will be like oh it's
about them like I think they're gonna
say you know it's about the money but
it's not about the money it's about that
like I know that the people watching
like a lot of times this is the
highlight of their day they've been
working a 40 50 60 hour a week job and
they're still choosing to give me a
Super Chat because they think that I'm
going to read it and I feel like like am
I gonna take away money from the average
person like okay if they go crazy far
and I and I actually clock it before I
read it sure but like it's more about
like that these people are supporting me
and sending their money and I just think
if someone is doing that like at
especially like they're average people
some of them just do it for fun to hear
you pronounce their surname's Mr
orajovsky or whatever his name is you
know the way he gets on putting it up I
watched that one he's I'm gonna say it
to see if she can say my surname again
was it a Russian or German surname yeah
and he kept on saying it but she knows
what it's all about guys you know you
know them guys that you're saying that's
reading them comments they're your
biggest followers do you need them what
are you gonna do in the comments and say
yo don't come out you've just hit the
point no but you've just hit the point
yeah I will start a podcast because I
want to change mindset not for money I
don't do it for money Pearl is doing it
for money two different things and she's
pushing a narrative which is toxic for
society I want to benefit men and women
so we get along and we have a better
life she wants to push this narrative
and make this hate wider can you tell me
okay now this is the funny thing now
technically it's the girl next to it's
not her but okay I want to tell you
something that happened Auntie Jenny so
oh you kind of you kind of know this but
I'm gonna tell I'm gonna tell everyone
blessing buckle up Kobe buckle up so
girl on the left apparently doesn't have
a podcast girl on the right has a
podcast now she invited me and Auntie
Jenny on now let's let's be wrong me and
Auntie Jenny get more views than these
girls will ever get in their lives I'm
not gonna allow but to use my followers
for rubbish because they were they're
gonna they're gonna follow or they're
gonna watch that podcast if I appeared
with her just say what I've got to say
and not only that she knows about
podcast
etiquette right but yeah when we watch
this listen to how listen and listen to
how they're gonna treat us and how why
they want us to come onto this show
you'll hear it dumb females
okay so she says it's not about money
right so why do you want us on your
podcast she said I thought it was about
conversation well if it's about
conversation we can have one not in
front of the camera if it's about
conversation she'd learn to shut her
mouth and have one when she's on the
podcast and two and two so what I said
what I said because why would I reward
you for bad behavior I again I'm very
thankful to the people that helped me
early on there are people especially
early on like daily on that podcast like
he helped us move when we moved into
this new apartment he helped us do it
and there's a lot of people that like
did stuff like that that I'm more than
willing to help um I went on I can't
remember the name but there's another
like smaller podcast in London I went on
and
I'm more than willing to do that but
like you're gonna trash me and then
expect me to go on a podcast for free
when typically I have a large fee that I
charge people and I only don't like if
you're one of those people that I feel
very grateful to so I said okay let's
let let's let domino effect make the
money we won't do it on my podcast I'll
offer you my studio let's let's let that
podcast make the money off of it because
it's not about it's right it's not about
money for them and they they call they
call Eddie and they're just like oh
convinced her to come on convince her to
come on like no we want it on our
podcast well if it's not about money you
should you should do it on Eddie's
remember it's the best didn't I when I
when I agreed I said that then she said
oh can you come on my podcast I said I
will go I will meet her I mean
Miss I don't know I'm a woman I miss I
will go on to the Domino effects podcast
with them but I'm not willing to go onto
her podcast so I'm not avoiding you
which is like talks about it about what
she said no like you're saying she